i
beau à Mayfield. Après
la tornade, un soleil radieux
qui se réveille sous un amas
de pieici presque
rien n'a été épargné.
Dès l'aube le nettoyagersrsrsrss
à travailler d'arrache-pied
pour redonner un semblant de vie
normale à cette communauté
de 10
Les équipes de secours
continuent leur fouille
mère en espérant un miracle
"On va partout avec nos chiens",
personne n'a été oublié".
Cette maison s'est littéralement
effondrée sur un enfant.
Sa mère a survécu et reçoit
William, le père, est sans
mots. Il a retrols de
mots. Il a retrouvé son fils de
3 ans mort sous les décombres.
la caméra. Son fils s'appelait
Jalil, il était ras
de sa mère avec son petit frère
lorsque le toit s'est affaissé
Les voisins tentent du mieux
qu'ils peuvent à apporterorteror
du réconfort.
Partout c'est la desolation.
Ce bureau de poste vieux das teu
non plus.
devastateur", dit-il.
"Heureusment il n'y avait pas
d'employés, on va déménager
nos bureaux dans la ville
reconstruire."
C'est ce qui reste duste dusteu
Carr Steak house; vendredi soir,
les employés fêtaient leur party
a appris qu'il y avait
rnade qui se dirigeait
vers la ville. Il a demandé à
tout le monde de quitter
les lieux. 20 min après,
la tornade s'est abattue ici.
Daniel Carr n'arrive toujours
pas à en croire ses yeux,
si lui et son frère n'avaient
pas réagi, rapidement.
"Quand j'ai su qade
allait frapper Mayfield, j'ai
appelé mon frère, il a réussi à
renvoyer tout le monde chez eux.
7 minutes avant que la tornade
s'abatrestaurant."
À quelques kilomètres de là,
l'usine de bougies n'a pas eu
la même chance. On continue à
compter les morts. 110 employés
travaiujours lorsque
la tornade a frappé.
t résilients", dit
le propriétaire. "On va essayer
de nous en sortir du mieux
qu'on peut. On va tout faire
pour aider nos employés",ajoute.
La tornade aura détruit en
quelques heures toute une ville
qui prendra certainement
des années à s'en remettre.
Ici Azeb Wolde-Ghiorgis
Radio-Canada, M